okay so as I said I'm Peter Cooper my
email address is there if you have any
questions you can always write to me
Peter Cooper at NIH gov that's pretty
easy we're gonna talk about what I mean
by genomic context that won't take long
and then I'm going to talk about
something called the identical proteins
group report and how to see the
corresponding genomic regions for a
blast it's so we're going to use sis
graphic view on blast to do that and
then at the end we'll wrap it up by
showing you some scripting ways to get
to some of this information using
edirect and some additional programs
because what do I mean by genomic
context I mean what genes or protein
products or regulatory sequences or
other sort of features are either
upstream or downstream and the genome
for match proteins and these are the
kinds of things that everybody is
interested in because they can tell you
about regulatory mechanisms it's useful
to know from a comparative genomics
perspective like you know how did this
particular set of genes how did they
change over time or their multiple
copies and some genomes and not and
others those kinds of things and also
another sort of way to use this would be
a quality check on sort of genome
assemblies annotation because you might
say hey you know what this genome is
missing this particular gene maybe that
is a problem with the assembly so you
could look at things like that so the
particular set of genes that we're going
to look at today or the ones that are
involved in the type 3 restriction to
nucleate its cassette this is a defense
mechanism that bacteria used one of them
to get rid of foreign DNA and this is a
typical example of what you see if you
look into a bacterial genome you'll see
that there is a helicase at the five
prime end of this thing there is the
methyl transferase which is the thing
that methylates bacterial the genomic
DNA of the host so that it doesn't get
cut and then there is a binding protein
this is the type 3 research and out
nucleate subunit are and so that's a
typical kind of situation and if you
look around you
there are some changes in this in some
kinds of bacteria but this is the one
sort of the canonical one that we're
going to be looking at today and what
we're gonna do is focus on the
site-specific DNA DNA methyl transferase
for the search of cities we're gonna
look for that find it in blast and then
take a look in the genome and see if
these other two genes are flanking it in
the genome that we're looking at okay so
if we're doing a nucleotide search this
is actually a fairly straightforward
thing to do now what I mean by
nucleotide search is I mean the database
you're searching is nucleotide because
what we're doing is we're looking down
in the alignment section and when we
have a tea blast in search like this one
where I search with a protein and I
matched a protein translation of a
genomic sequence I can click that
graphics link and that will take me
directly to a view of that genomic
sequence in our graphical sequence
viewer like this one and there is my
protein match there there's a number of
mismatches there you can see that at the
bottom of my screen here this for these
red marks or mismatches but that's still
a very good protein blast match that's a
key blast in alignment of the query
against the subject sequence which is
this whole genome shotgun sequence from
this particular bacterium and in fact if
you check these the annotation of these
genes on your side they are similar to
the ones that I showed you a minute ago
although one of them is labeled a
hypothetical protein in fact if you take
that and do a blast search with it
you'll see that it matches one of the
other two things the de site specific
bevel transferase is annotated in the
right way so the genomic context in this
particular case is conserved and we saw
it simply by clicking one link on the
blast outpoint now what a lot of people
though do when they do these kinds of
searches or protein searches and in part
you really the new with he was in search
against a large set of bacterial genomes
this kind of burdensome and it takes a
long time and it may fail for various
reasons so protein is more likely to
work the problem is the graphics link
here doesn't do what you might think it
does or doesn't
what we saw a minute ago it takes you to
the protein sequence graphic which
doesn't tell you about the genomic
context however there is another link
that's often shown on the right hand
side when we when there's more than one
protein available in this thing called
the identical proteins like a notice
that this is a particular kind of
protein accession number that starts
with a w and a p this is one of our non
redundant refseq bacterial proteins I'll
talk more about that in a minute so if I
link to the protein itself and there are
sort of entrees system a protein web
database I can see a link to identical
proteins there and I can follow the link
directly to the IPG report and this is a
list of first of all all the proteins
that are identical there may be in
several gen pepped submitted sequences
that are identical to this reference
sequence that starts with a WP but the
WP is annotated on a number of different
genomic sequences and so you can see
those in the second column of the table
on the right hand side of this slide and
if I follow the link to one of those it
will take me to that coding region in
the CBS region in the nucleotide
database with that particular range and
that particular strand of the DNA
focused in on so that will give me a way
of looking at the corresponding coding
regions and all of these bacteria that
have this protein annotated on them and
so for example this is the protein the
link from the protein that we're going
to be looking at this genome and
minimally this is a Salmonella enterica
assembly I'm just looking at this 3,000
or so base pair up arctic corresponds to
the coding region of the blast match and
if you want to try to look at that view
yourself the link is there in this slide
and if I follow this to the genomic view
I can just manipulate the graphics view
a little bit to the graphics views what
I clicked on here and I can just take a
look at the things surrounding that
particular coding region so that's the
one that we were zoomed in on a minute
ago and that
labeled as a site-specific DNA
methyltransferase which is exactly what
I would expect my blast search to match
now remember we're not going directly
from blast so it doesn't show you the
alignment in this particular case
because we were just aligned protein to
protein but I'm looking at the region on
the genome that corresponds to that
protein upstream of that is that ATP
dependent helicase that we saw at the
beginning when we were talking about
sort of a canonical version of this and
then on the other side is that type 3
restriction perking the binding site
unit so that was concerned we saw that
by following the links to the identical
protein report and then to the graphical
sequence viewer so that's how you would
do it on the web and I'll demonstrate
that stuff live in a few minutes the
other thing I want to mention is that
you can access these identical protein
group reports using the API in
particular we're going to focus on using
direct to do that and we have a number
of webinars on a direct or if you want
more background on a direct you can go
to our YouTube playlist and the link is
there on this particular slide what a
direct is is a UNIX command-line version
of the entree utilities or the
e-utilities which is the api for our
entree system lets you search and
retrieve records from all of our
databases
it has processing scripts and an XML
parser called extract in each program
outputs XML you can pipe it into another
direct program or a Linux UNIX utility
for processing okay and we've talked
about this a number of times in various
webinars in fact one last week and
certainly take a look at the
documentation which is very extensive
and explains a lot about using you
direct so I won't have time today to
talk a lot about that but I want to just
point out some things that are useful
that you can do with these particular
reports and we're going to be focusing
on e fetch and ilyich then the program
extract to look at some various things
so the format IPG
argument to extract will give you that
identical proteins group table that we
saw a minute ago and here's an example
of how I could retrieve that and get the
IPG report on the command line the other
thing that's going to be useful to us if
we want to get the genomic context once
we know what sequence we're going to be
looking at is we want to use a
particular kind of XML that's called GBC
it's a special XML format
that has sort of these wrappers or
built-in extract functions that let you
parse out features from the feature
table and for example this rather
complicated looking command line here at
the bottom there I'm retrieving this
record from the nucleotide database in
the format GBC I'm passing it through
extract and what extract is using this
insdc argument to look at this CVS
feature and within that feature there
are these various qualifiers that you
can output simply by giving their names
so I can get the interval and I can get
the protein ID so we can use that in a
very crude way today to get that
information so here's what we're gonna
do we're gonna go to the web and do some
web blast stuff and really I'm not going
to run the searches I'm just going to
show you the results because I've
already run them it'll save us some time
but I'll show you how to get to the
graphics view and how to do the things I
talked about and then we'll talk a
little bit sort of touch on using you
direct to get these things out using the
command line I'll show you how to do
with a single report and then we'll sort
of begin to talk about how you would do
with blast output that's a more
difficult problem because you have lots
and lots of IBG reports in there for one
for each protein and each one of those
could have many many corresponding
genomic regions ultimately for in some
cases if you wanted to do this in in
large quantity you probably want to go
to the assembly database and download
the corresponding GFF files or the
annotation files for the particular
something I'll talk about that more in
just a minute
so anyway what we're going to do with
this is we're going to get these
nucleotide records and we're going to
look at the neighboring genes one up one
down to see if they're the same or
they're conserved just like we saw a
minute ago in those screenshots of the
web okay so let me escape out of the
slides and what we're going to be doing
for our blast searches is I sort of went
through a whole genome shotgun assembly
of a metagenomic project and I found an
open reading frame in there that
corresponds to one of these methyl
transferase and so we'll use that as a
query sequence when we're doing our
blast search today if you want to see
what that project is the link is here in
this handout okay so the first things
we're going to do is just take a look at
web searches and remember we did a
search against a nucleotide database and
the one that I did was this T blast n
search against representative genomes so
all I'm doing is just taking that r ID
which i've saved and this should be
valid for several months because i
preserve it it won't be valid forever
but it should work for the short term
this is T blast insert so this took a
few minutes to run but you can see there
are all these hits to complete genomes
and we can pick any one of these we want
to look at the corresponding graphical
view to see you know whether we think
this is conserved and actually I'm just
going to pick one that I haven't looked
at before so let's see if we get the
same results here so I'm gonna think is
God chloro beum complete genome here let
me just jump to that in the alignment
section and there's our T blast in
alignment but now if I click on the
graphics link here either one will give
me the same thing because there's only
one hit to this particular genome so it
looks like we have some you know some
differences in annotation than what we
saw a minute ago which is fine this is
the kind of thing that you can identify
by looking at this so it did identify
this open reading frame here as a
site-specific DNA methyltransferase but
then there are so also some things that
are sort of part of that match that
come up as annotated as separate
proteins now that may or may not be
correct but so we already are seeing
some genomic context of the blast it's
here there are two genes annotated in
this region I can zoom out to see what
else is around so here's the gene that's
immediately to the 5-prime of that it
says that's a transpose a is again
that's different than what we think of
as the canonical version of this with
this interesting and a good it does give
you the genomic context and this is
another different gene there so we can
keep looking around if we want to to see
what's available now that's another case
here we have it looks like we have an
extra gene here but the next stream down
next gene downstream is that type 3
researching a nuclease subunit like we
expected to find so this is an
interesting kind of finding and if you
were interested in the biology of this
organism this would be useful for you to
know ok so that's that blast result I'm
going to close the graphical overview
here for that one now let's go ahead and
get the other kind of blast results with
those protein results that we talked
about a minute ago and in this case I
blasted that protein sequence that we
saw against the refseq protein database
which will give me entirely for bacteria
anyway it will give me entirely WP style
records and so you can see that our
methylase has this nice type 3
restriction methyl a superfamily
modification here so that's good that's
what we would expect and we have hits to
lots of WP style proteins from lots of
organisms that you probably recognize
the names of here's one Salmonella
enterica and this is the one that we
were looking at and it slides a moment
ago so let's go ahead and get that one
so I'll jump down to the alignment
section here
and so I don't see the I'm not sure that
this is just a bug today but uh the
particular link to the identical
proteins is not there but it doesn't
matter because I can obviously get it by
going directly to the record itself
mm-hmm and that's a bug but let's see if
we can still get the identical proteins
reported okay that's fine
okay so we do have a talk with proteins
report this is a nice table that lets me
see pakodi region so I can pick a
particular of Salmonella that I want
like right here I'll just do the first
one and again we resume down looking at
this particular coding region on this
genome I can go to the graphical view
here and there's my protein and as we
already know because the protein says so
it's a site-specific DNA
methyltransferase but now I can zoom out
a little bit and see what's there and of
course we've already seen this and my
slide show a moment ago so there's the
atp-dependent helicase there's our
methyl transferase and there is the
restriction binding site right there
okay so those are the two things that
you can see in blast and how to get the
genomic context for these matches okay
now let's go and we're going to switch
now back and forth between this sort of
page here and we're going to start using
a direct and so this will be fairly
quick but you can always come back to
this and get these command lines if you
want to practice using you direct so let
me just grab the first one here first of
all I'm just going to get the IPG report
so you can see that it's the same thing
so I'm going to search the protein
database for this protein record the one
that we saw a minute ago and I'm gonna
ask for the IPG format so we get this
nice report here it's just like the one
we saw on the web one of the things I
want to do is to focus on the refseq
Sitter in here notice that there is an
entry here on the table that says i N
SDC that's Genta frickert and it's
identical teas refseq proteins that are
in here these WP sessions it's all this
one WP so what I want to do is to clean
that up and just get the refseqs I can
just use awk which is sort of a Swiss
Army knife for dealing with have a
limited output I can say just give me
the refseqs that's going to be in column
two you know what I'll print out of that
is simply the nucleotide accession
numbers so what we can do with those is
we can go back in and we can retrieve
those in that other format I talked
about and go ahead and parse out the
feature table to get the flanking genes
on either side of this in this way that
I'm suggesting doing this is not a very
sophisticated way and certainly you
might be able to think of better ways to
do it but it certainly makes the point
that it can be done so here's what I'm
going to do there's a lot of sort of
extra business in here I'll sort of talk
about what's important for this
particular command line here okay
so we've already done this I'm going to
get the WP and the IPG format I'm gonna
get out just those nucleotide accessions
that are in column three I'm just gonna
pass the first two just to show you
quickly what happens but then I'm gonna
pass those two things to e fetch that's
what this XR treats businesses and
that's very well discussed and document
that goes with direct and how to use it
so I'm gonna go to new core and get
these guys from the new core database in
the GBC format and then I'm going to use
that extract command to get the all of
the coding regions and then I'm gonna do
something really crude basically just
use grep to get that particular coding
region the one before it
the one after it so let me do that so
those are the first two and they are
indeed exactly the same
the atp-dependent helicase the
site-specific DNA methyltransferase and
the type 3 restriction protein and you
could even like
in this a little more to get you know to
up to down if you want to and that's
what this next command line does there's
nothing particularly special about it
except I just changed the grep
parameters instead of running out I'll
just show you what the result is okay so
you can see the only real difference so
I've got two up two down here the only
real difference you'll notice if you
look through sometimes they're flipped
around because the particular coding
region is on the opposite strand and so
the order is sometimes different but the
genes are the same unlike we saw a
minute ago in the Blas where they were
not the same but in this particular case
they are these are all the Salmonella
assemblies that we saw a minute ago
now what about doing that for a blast
result so what I did was I took one of
those blast searches that we have I did
a minute ago and I saved it from the web
on to my hard drive and then I can go
ahead and class and search that and get
the IPG reports and that's what this
does here it basically parses the blast
report and we have a webinar that's all
about doing that if you want to see you
that so basically what I'm getting is
all of those I just did the first ten
that was a hundred different class
things and so you just got the basic IPG
reports for all of those it's kind of
confusing cuz it's a word it wraps the
you know lines are too long but it's you
can see these are the IPG reports for
all them
now you could parse this with a script
if you want to and do the same kinds of
things that we did before with the other
ones the only issue is you've got to now
have you have a different WP and you'd
have to go through and write a script to
handle this in a more sophisticated way
so you know you can argue I can rewrite
this if I want to I can get this in a
little bit more human readable format
where it gets the Assembly accession
sort of highlights that for you and
that's sort of the next sort of way to
do this and I'm not going to go through
all this but you're certainly welcome to
take a look at this and see the sort of
strategy the idea here is to go ahead
and head and get the
assembly out of the last column that
would be printed out here I'll go ahead
and trade that file then there are some
strategies that are documented fairly
well on the genomes downloaded about how
to download particular files from the
assembly directory the file that I would
recommend you do this with is a GF f3
file for each one of these and then it's
a very simple matter because it's a
single line per coding region and you
can parse those out of there pretty
easily so I'll just show you that refseq
IPG report here and then we'll stop for
some questions so that's just a lie used
to talk to sort of simplify that report
a little bit but you can continue along
those lines and go ahead and get go to a
search against the assembly database
using a direct to get the path to the
FTP directory that contains the assembly
files you could write in another script
or make it more complicated script that
could go ahead and pull down the GFF
file for each one of these and parse it
for the particular proteins of interest
but of course you have to have a
different protein for particular one of
these assemblies sometimes okay so I'll
stop there and see if anybody has any
questions I will leave it open for a
couple minutes in case somebody thinks
is something at the last minute so what
we saw is that you can link to the IPG
report to get the nucleotide coding
region for web last near confess and
parse protein IBT reports using that GBC
xml with e direct and other command-line
tools for a single report or for the
standard line phone blast output and the
last slide has a number of URLs many of
these i've mentioned in the slides
earlier but you might want to download
that and take a look at that if you want
to visit any these things in particular
take a look at the youtube playlist for
eat erect and the e direct manual if
you're interested in doing more things
with eat erect hi Peter we have one
quick question at this point one of our
users is interested in how we can get
the T blast end results in the form of
protein sequences using the web not eat
right so you basically you want to get
the translations of the genome right he
wants to get the protein translations so
where there are matches like the ones I
saw where you are matching annotated
genomic sequences yes you can do that
because you could do the same kind of
sort of process where you could go and
find the annotated proteins however if
you're talking about doing a T blessin's
search against something like a w GS
record or another kind of uh Nana tative
nucleotide sequence there is no way for
you to get the corresponding coding
regions you can take the nucleotide
sequence which is what I did to make
that protein that we used as a query and
go to our or finder and do a six frame
translations on that to get your to get
the particular open reading frame that's
on it that's what you wanted to do so I
guess that's the answer you'd have to
take the genomic DNA hit and do some
kind of translation yourself the or
finder on our website will let you do
that and I can quickly show you where
that is in case you don't know so it's
just the ncbi URL and then or finder as
a single word and you can put your open
reading frame or an accession number
right in here to generate and it will
generate the protein sequence for you it
doesn't do it in bulk and it doesn't
don't think it does it in a way that
will let you download these things but
we can check that out and I'll put the
more elaborate answer in the Q&A
document that goes along with this Ron
is there anything else the same person
was interested in how to translate 2,000
hits using the web and that's not
possible
but we can put an example in the
documentation after this webinar on the
web on the FTP
as to how you can actually get your
protein sequences out there's another
question that somebody had which is he's
interested in IP jeez
but he wants to know if you can filter
the IPG clusters shown to those that
have specific sets of organisms and he's
interested in a direct or you know using
scripting can you filter the IPG hits
that are returned to those that only
have like a certain group of organisms
so I think if I understand the question
is yes you can you can actually search
IPG and I'm not positive you can do you
can search IP G on the web I haven't
tried it really on the command line but
it ought to work the same way you can
put an organism query in there and it
will give you the clusters back the
inter the identical protein groups back
that have that particular organism in
them I think that answers a question but
I'm not sure there is a separate IP G
actually has its own interface you can
search here we weren't really talking
about this database per se today we were
talking the link to this database and
the format that you can get for from the
protein side but there is a way to
search the IPG reports in this this
particular way okay well I think I will
close then with that thank you very much
for coming and I'm going to end the
webinar now
you